yo I hope you got your coffee ready
because this is another video request
for you guys some of you asked and said
hey Daniel what is the best supplements
for hair growth and thickness so that's
what I'm gonna talk about in this video
let's not waste any more time let's get
right to it so good hey guys welcome
here on my channel if this is the first
time you're here I'm Daniel and
subscribe click the notification belt so
you won't miss any of the next videos
alright so let's start with the first
supplement for hair growth and things
while it's in from Seoul garner biotin
is a vitamin b-complex and so it
strengthens the protein infrastructure
of your hair your nails and your skin
now this basic protein infrastructure is
called carotene so I would suggest you
get the super high potency biotin from
soulguard and as always I'll add the
links of all the products for you in the
video description so you can go ahead
and check it out yourself just a bit
easier also check out the customer
reviews of people that tried it out
before alright let's move onto the next
one
flaxseed oil from nature may why
but because flaxseed they have omega-3
fatty acids which helps your hair
follicles to stay healthy and retain
water and produce seven he's got over
400 of happy customer reviews on Amazon
check it out in the video description
[Music]
folic acid from nature made enough folic
acid
well aka v9 helps tissue tree Grove and
circulation which helps your hair
follicles to function properly
in him an A and C why well both of them
helped your body to produce seven which
is the natural oil that protects your
hair and keeps it strong
[Music]
Zink from garden of life now Zink is
very important for your hair why because
if your body if you don't have enough
zinc you can actually lose hair so zinc
is important for maintaining scalp
health through cell reproduction tissue
growth and repair now just on the last
advice although some of these
supplements might work and will help you
out with your hair growth and the
thickness the most important thing is
nutrition if you have a poor nutrition
it's not just gonna show in your hair
but you know overall appearance as well
now if you struggle with hair loss I've
added a few extra products for in the
video description that will definitely
help you out if you like the video give
a thumbs up subscribe and I'll see you
in the next video Cheers
you